[Musique]
la situation
terre qui continue de stagner en france
5959 passion était en réanimation hier
soit 25 de moins que la veille
le pic de la troisième vague semble donc
derrière nous et la baisse de la
pression épidémique est engagé est-ce
que d'ici trois semaines
on peut diviser par trois le nombre de
patients dans nos animations
c'est la question est donc c'est à
partir d'indicateurs qu'il faut décider
et pas au doigt mouillé et sur le
calendrier le trio a confirmé les
rumeurs de ces derniers jours les écoles
maternelles et élémentaires ouvriront
donc la semaine prochaine les collèges
et les lycées reprendront à partir du 3
mai en présentiel
effectivement ça c'est une préoccupation
parce que c'est une source majeure de
kloster familiaux et donc de reprise de
la pandémie qui est absolument pas
contrôlé à partir du 3 mai également
nous pourrons lever les contraintes de
déplacement en journée et envisager un
nouveau train de réouverture autour de
la mi mai qui pourrait commencer par les
commerces certaines activités
culturelles et sportives et les
terrasses
c'est le grand secret en france en
europe pendant les gens ne veulent pas
en entendre parler de ça mais on ne
tient plus que par la banque centrale
européenne qui imprime de la monnaie de
singe pour racheter les dettes publiques
que sinon les états ne pourraient pas
placer sur les marchés financiers on est
tous suspendus aujourd'hui au bon
vouloir de christine lagarde et de la
banque centrale européenne pour savoir
si oui ou non ils continuent d'acheter
des dettes publiques
est ce compliqué j'ai des pertes de
mémoire aussi c'est j'ai un bébé de 7
mois est déjà suffisamment
non si à un moment ou un autre pour une
raison x y ou z
eh bien il arrive qu'ils n'y arrivent
plus on plongera tout c'est ça on est
aujourd'hui l'économie l'économie
française en particulier
c'est un château de cartes vue de
l'extérieur la france c'est pas beaucoup
mieux que le brésil nous on se moque du
brésil on regarde ça mais pour les pays
étrangers il compare la france au brésil
on a quand même passé les cent mille
morts et on continue on continue à voir
une mortalité extrêmement élevé donc moi
je comprends que les gens disent bon bah
écoutez moi j'ai un ami médecin qui me
dit on s'en tape ils ont 85 ans mais
c'est d'abord c'est scandaleux
mais ensuite c'est pas vrai les
nouvelles ce matin du maire écologiste
de lyon grégory douce et il vient d'être
papa pour la quatrième fois et si je
vous dis ça c'est parce qu'il a décidé
de se mettre en retrait pour onze jours
de congé paternité
c'est très rare en politique c'est pour
ça qu'on en parle ce matin
vous venez de résumer la pensée complexe
de marlène schiappa be et bien vous
venez aussi de montrer et souligné son
rôle c'est à dire d'être la principale
vrp aujourd'hui je suis désolé mais du
rassemblement national avec ce sommet
dit de la dernière chance washington
compte bien faire pression sur le reste
du monde et montrer que les états unis
sont de retour dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
après les années trump à la maison
blanche pour l'ouverture
joe biden a même a fait une grosse
annonce un sous marins portés disparus
au large de ben ali la marine
indonésienne a entamé des recherches
mercredi après avoir perdu le contact
avec le bâtiment certains d'entre eux
affichent déjà des chiffres ambitieux
pour empêcher le réchauffement
planétaire d'un degré 5 le royaume uni
annonce baissé de 78 % ses émissions
d'ici 2
35 l'union européenne de 55 % d'ici 2030
les premiers secours arrivés sur place
ont localisé une nappe d'hydrocarbures à
la surface seule trace du bâtiment qui
fait craindre le pire